so you you are staunchly in favor of
abortion I am your captive audience
if you had to give me the elevator pitch
what would it be absolutely so what I
would really like to start this
conversation off with and make very
clear from the start for both you and
your viewers is I am not saying that you
are wrong for being uncomfortable with
abortion I'm not saying that you are
wrong for not agreeing with it but your
opinion applies to your body and your
life alone we are not sitting here
having a discussion about our personal
disagreements I am here to educate you
and your viewers on the guidelines of
proper Medical Practice that have been
established by our country's leading
medical experts and they have stated
publicly and unequivocally that abortion
access is essential to comprehensive
evidence-based health care and we both
want to protect life and what remains
true is protecting innocent life never
involves restricting Access to Health
Care so
two questions I have from that you
mentioned that all of the genius medical
people agree in our country that we need
to have abortion
now surely all of the genius medical
people have agreed on all sorts of
practices throughout history even in the
not so distant past that are all that
are quite terrible for people one good
example would be lobotomies there was a
scientific consensus in the country that
when women are behaving a little
eccentric we should go in and scramble
up their brains and they use these kinds
of procedures throughout the 20th
century now we look at that as ghastly
and and a violation of basic rights but
this was a medical consensus so surely
you're not telling me that just because
a bunch of fancy people in lab coats
think something about a matter of
bioethics that therefore it's the gospel
truth
well a big part of the prior you know
travesties of medicine is there was not
consent from patients and there wasn't
proper informed consent from patients
where when it comes to abortion you
continuously say that I am pro-abortion
when really I am pro-abortion access and
abortion access and the discussion of
having an abortion should be between the
patient and the medical provider and
that is it and the entire concept and
the entire point is that the pregnant
person gets to consent to continue with
their pregnancy and must consent to the
use of their body because they are the
one that understands their body and
their life and their finances and
everything that makes up the
complexities of human life they are the
only ones who are able to decide and
understand what is best for them with
the guidance of you know proper modern
medical practices and it is true that
our world and our country's leading
medical Minds have like I said on
unequivocally stated that abortion
access is essential to comprehensive
evidence-based health care and your
opinion can remain your opinion but it
does not get to override the opinion of
people who train their entire lives to
provide Health Care to people well so on
the matter of consent obviously the
clear rebuttal to that would be that
abortion involves not two people but
three people one of whom is the unborn
baby now I imagine you would have issues
with that description so we can get to
that in a moment the first thing you
said though is that I'm entitled to my
opinion but I'm only entitled to my
opinion as it pertains to my own body
and I'm not entitled to to an opinion
about what you do with your own body but
do you really believe that do you really
believe that people can only have
opinions about things that pertain to
their physical selves I can't have an
opinion about I don't know a sunset or I
don't know how automobiles are made or I
don't know drug use or anything like I
can't have an opinion about politics our
government should be run or how our
political Community ought to behave I
can only have opinions about myself
and I think you misunderstand me you can
have your opinion about anything and
anyone that you'd like but that opinion
cannot restrict someone's access to
health care you can agree disagree with
someone's choice to get an abortion but
just because you disagree with it
doesn't mean that your opinion should
override the opinion of their medical
experts can can my opinion
be put into effect to restrict someone's
access to drugs like heroin
well in what way well we have
self-government in the United States at
least nominally and so if I think that
heroin is really bad and I think we
ought to have laws against its use then
I can Lobby my elected representatives
and they can pass a law as they have
against heroin and then you are not
allowed to use heroin even though that
affects only your own body I have now
expressed my opinion about heroin in
such a way that restricts what you can
do with your own body are you saying
that that is not acceptable so actually
with laws regarding drugs it is illegal
to buy and sell drugs but it's not
actually illegal to do drugs because you
can't tell depends on the jurisdiction
but true but it you cannot tell me what
I can or cannot do with my body again
you can totally and rightfully so
disagree with someone's choice to do
drugs but that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't as health care providers
ensure that that say drug user is able
to make informed choices about their
body are you familiar with like clean
needle programs oh yeah correct and so
clean needle programs they reduce
disease transmission and so even though
someone is going to choose to do drugs
it is the responsibility of medical
experts and health care providers to
ensure that we cannot you know we cannot
change someone's choices in behavioral
patterns but we can ensure that we
provide them resources and able to
ensure that their decisions and the
impact of their decisions is minimized
in whatever way that we can Bronte
putting aside for a moment the efficacy
of clean needle programs which I think
is dubious but that might be a
discussion for another day I think
you're evading the question a little bit
here because you're suggesting that drug
use is not criminal in all cases which
is not the case there are places where
drug use is quite where the use of the
drugs itself is Criminal but even so
let's let's take that let's accept your
premise
nevertheless purchasing the drugs would
be illegal now this is something you do
with your own body with your own money
this is uh it's the very same issue just
removed One Step so is it is it all
right for me to express my opinion about
illicit drug use to restrict you from
doing something that you want to do be
that shooting the heroine purchasing the
heroin putting the heroine in a syringe
whatever you want to say clearly I am
restricting your bodily autonomy here
and that has been done throughout
civilization that remains on the books
in the United States are you saying that
drug laws are basically some sort of
travesty no of course not because it's a
matter of public health now when we talk
about pregnancy and abortion essentially
what causes pregnancy is sex correct and
we cannot Outlaw sex unless that's
something that you are trying to bring
forth and so when it comes to you know
laws limiting someone's ability to have
bodily autonomy or you know limit
someone's ability ability to behave in a
certain way this is sex and pregnancy
and abortion is a very unique
circumstance and sure we can talk all
day about some convoluted you know drug
analogy but at the end of the day well I
know that's your opinion but we cannot
Outlaw sex and sex happens for numerous
reasons and pregnancy can be accidental
and unwanted and so trying to compare it
to illegalizing drug use it's not
completely analogous to illegalizing and
banning abortion because sex and drug
use are two very different things and
they happen for two very different
reasons well I suppose I'm just
discussing the principle that you
described earlier which is that I I
don't have the right to an opinion that
affects what you do with your own body
but even leaving that aside you say that
we can't make sex illegal I don't think
anybody wants to make sex illegal but
historically all sorts of sex has been
illegal and all sorts of sex remains
illegal today there are certain sexual
behaviors Even in our more decadent and
inclusive
that are illegal obviously sex with
children or sex with animals things like
that historically sex uh outside of
marriage has been illegal in many places
homosexual sexual activity has been
illegal in many places so we've had laws
in the United States and continue to
have laws that regulate sex uh all of
that though I wonder so historically you
know those are the facts and doesn't
that seem to be a little bit beside the
point when it comes to abortion because
now we're saying no that you know of
consenting adults above the age of 18
they can have all the sex they want but
if you do have sex and you do get
pregnant well you don't have the right
to kill the baby